let's start with uh bitcoin in general
it's continued to bleed down it was 69
000 in november it's like 20 000 today
uh if you go on the internet half the
people are crying and screaming the
other half are posting memes what's
going on yeah it's shocking i'd honestly
i didn't expect it to uh to get this low
um i think it's just a huge amount of
leverage it's being flushed out of the
the crypto industry right now obviously
it's um you know tara kind of kicked it
off and then you sort of like get these
cascading
failures um a lot of a lot of people
thought there was sort of a daisy chain
of risk
um and uh between d5 uh centralized
lenders
uh and then sort of like these uh
origination
uh sources of risk like tara uh that's
happening you know you like you can
trace a causal chain from the blow up of
things like tara uh to
uh celsius uh to certain funds that are
impaired um you know to to some of the
larger lenders in the space um so you
know bitcoin is implicated in that uh
bitcoin is sort of you know key
collateral in the system and as you have
these forced liquidations
you just you know you never want to be a
force seller but that's what we're
seeing a ton of force selling right now
and so a lot of this just goes back to
leverage in the system and leverage
exists in the legacy system it exists in
this system as well are you surprised at
how well the system has stood up to
liquidations people selling in some
cases we've seen people have to sell you
know 80 000 bitcoin or whatever it is um
if this was the legacy system like i
would think at this point there would be
bailout talk and government stepping in
you know there's none of that in bitcoin
and crypto land i mean i was just joking
last night i wish we had a lender of
last resort
don't let the trad five people hear us
say that uh i mean uh frankly actually
defy has held up really well i'd say in
terms of uh performing an orderly manner
i initially was impressed that the
crypto industry as a whole was able to
weather the celsius or not celsius the
terra
blow up
which would evaporate around 60 billion
in nominal value without too much
um you know knockout effects but then it
looks like we're seeing those knock-on
effects now
with the delay
um so
yeah i i think there was a huge huge
amount of leverage
built up both in d5 and the c5 corners
of the market and we're really really
suffering without overhang now it
doesn't help that financial conditions
are about as tight as they've ever been
you know i think the fed is probably
going to have to
reverse course here at some point and
they're sort of posturing you know being
like the the volcker and you know really
sticking it to inflation stuff like that
so it doesn't help it's really a perfect
storm so when you look at that perfect
storm obviously we have the fed which
said couple weeks ago hey we're gonna do
50 basis point hikes in june and july
that was kind of their signal uh now
there was a leak two days ago that they
may do 75 basis points in june which
many people read into that be june and
july
they have started to conduct
quantitative tightening um what's your
read on like the federal reserve they're
in control and just the more aggressive
they are we should expect asset prices
to sell off
i think they're in the opposite of
control i think they uh are in a really
tight spot here
you know fundamentally if you zoom out a
little bit
the
fed can't raise rates to whip inflation
here
without
basically bankrupting everything
there is so much debt in the system both
at the sovereign and the corporate level
that if you allow rates to rise
um
people become insolvent really quickly
uh and you could say crypto's a canary
in the coal mine there so
um if you look back at the 1970s when
was the last time we had inflation this
bad
um
paul volcker raised rates to 20 or
thereabouts
and uh that was a contributing factor in
um you know
containing inflation
now
if you raise rates to five percent
uh the u.s government would default
right because our debt to gdp ratio is
120
as opposed to 30 as it was back then and
our deficit is around seven percent this
year
as opposed to uh two three percent as it
was back then so the system cannot
tolerate
uh rising interest rates
um so i don't actually believe that the
fed can sort of carry out the stated
agenda i know they're talking really
tough and they're posturing but i think
what's actually in store for us is
something more like yield curve control
which we're seeing in japan right now
where you're capping yields at a very
low rate and you're printing unlimited
amounts of fiat in order to cap those
yields
uh because
i don't think there's appetite for um
you know cutting
entitlement spending or defense spending
or anything like that so i'll start this
out of the picture
um and i don't think there's appetite
for default obviously the us
government's never gonna default
so uh the only thing that we can
actually do here
uh is actually an inflationary uh pivot
here now i don't know what the effect of
that will be on asset prices but um
things are already breaking in the
financial system if you look closely
we're seeing basically any macro chart
that you look at
whether it's two year
treasuries
whether it's the price the yen
whether it's mortgage-backed security
market
all of these things are showing enormous
stress and the rapidity of these moves
is breathtaking
so i think the fed is actually going to
be responding to that
some commentators say they have a shadow
third mandate which is the orderly
functioning of the bond market
as that bond market starts to break and
it is breaking my opinion if you look at
a lot of these indicators
uh they're going to have to revisit
their sort of proposed agenda here
a couple weeks ago i was talking to
folks and and i said that while i would
not bet on it i do think that there's an
outsized chance that we will actually
get a rate cut before the end of the
year is that your viewpoint as well or
how do you think about like where this
goes through the end of december yeah i
share the view of commentators like
zoltan pozar or luke roman or lynn alden
that basically
uh it would be
genuinely impossible especially in an
election year
for the fed to
keep hiking here because that crushes
asset prices that reduces tax receipts
tax receipts are basically a function of
asset prices now
it uh crushes the economy
and
you know it's basically sending us not
into recession territory but into
depression territory right now if they
continue on their sort of trajectory uh
so i don't believe that they're going to
do that because that would be an insane
thing to do
uh and i believe that uh they'll reverse
course i think they just started
reducing uh their balance sheet as of a
couple days ago um
i yeah i don't fundamentally i don't
think the us can even handle four
percent um
rates here um it's just you know the
amount of debt and leverage that's built
up is so so considerable if you had to
pick an over under how high they get
before they reverse course is it like
two percent three percent two and a half
percent i would say uh the reversal
um
will come no later than q4 this year q4
yeah um ecb holding an emergency meeting
i think last night or this morning um
how do you read into like other central
banks right obviously the ecb said hey
we're going to keep rates negative uh we
don't care what the fed's doing we're
going to kind of break from them then
they reverse course and they said oh
actually maybe we'll go back to kind of
zero percent interest rates and then
we'll follow now they have emergency
rate meetings like it just seems chaotic
like what are these other central banks
thinking in regards to the fed yeah i
will admit i'm sort of like quite
parochial so i'm mostly a fed watcher
and i don't really understand what's
going on in europe it just seems insane
um i would say like fundamentally
europe's problem is that they
um you know have an energy crisis and
sort of like everything follows from
that the other problem is that they're
trying to unite all these disparate
economies um under a single monetary
policy which doesn't seem to work and it
ends up just being highly um you know
leading to inegalitarian outcomes and
they've got this one blunt weapon
um
the central bank you know aside from the
us i'm watching right now is japan
um they're imposing yield curve control
right so they're capping yields i think
at 25 basis points
and um even though they've unlimited
funds to um
keep you know keep the pressure
uh impose that ceiling on yields um
incredibly i think it traded above 25
basis points uh a couple days ago
um which is crazy because you're trading
in something with infinite ammo the
printing press um and so uh and the yen
is um is you know depreciating
enormously rapidly as a consequence of
that so that kind of is a i think that's
a glimpse into our future
uh is yield curve control keeping rates
low in order to keep the government
solvent and then the exit valve is
the dollar yeah and so when you think
about this um inflation obviously at 8.6
percent i think they thought it peaked
in march uh april looked like okay that
narrative was gonna stick now we kind of
accelerate hit uh a new 40-year high um
do you expect like price controls as
well like you're talking about yield
controls and all that but like if
inflation continues to run up we've
already seen politicians talking about
price gouging or corporate greed et
cetera like argentina's got plenty of
price control should we expect in the
u.s at some point yes yield curve
control is the ultimate price control
right um
you're trying to control uh what the
market thinks about the solvency of the
biggest borrower which is u.s government
so that alone is a price control
to impose it if you want to look at
history when did we last have it we had
in the 1940s when we were dealing with
basically a similar situation enormously
high
debt to gdp
uh we just fought a war
we had that sort of overhang of the huge
huge deficits
we'd had zero rates uh before that so
similar situation i think the 40s is
your analogous situation as many
commentators including lynn alden have
been saying
um and what was life like in the 40s
well there was rationing right you could
only like buy so much sugar and flour
like you know that's kind of the world
that you want to look to there were
capital controls right
and and that's the thing with yield
curve control you can't just impose it
you have to um really restrict where
people can put their savings you have to
force financial institutions endowments
pensions banks
you know mutual funds to hold treasuries
you have to force them to hold it nobody
wants to hold them right they're a toxic
asset that's what monetary repression is
you run inflation hot and you keep
interest rates low the government's able
to reset its balance sheet based on that
delta
but the way they do that is by forcing
savers to hold these terrible negative
yielding government debt instruments and
so you create that through you create
that
environment of monetary repression
uh by
you know determining what people can and
can't do um you know gold at that point
you couldn't hold it in the 40s it was
illegal
and so i expect that i also do expect
price controls because you're looking an
inflationary environment governments are
going to react with these crazy
short-term measures
uh we just had biden this morning i
think asking oil companies to explain
why they're making some money so much
money so it's like a crazy town out
there and yeah i think you're going to
look at stuff that you see typically in
emerging markets you're going to look at
the government trying to uh you know
deal with these symptoms and not the
underlying cause
what should the fed do like i get that
they are responding to
current economic situation i get that uh
there is an implicit uh political
pressure given that there's midterm
elections uh but they claim that they
are independent and not aware of that
there's also a claim that they don't pay
attention to asset prices and can kind
of stomach whatever happens there
but what do you think is like the answer
for them or is there actually a
situation where it's like lose lose and
they don't really have an option is pick
the best of the worst options yeah we're
like um we're we're dealing for our
historical mistakes here right so we've
had like uh 70 years of debt
accumulation we've been on pure fiat for
50 years
um
the whole system is highly leveraged
we're at the worst uh sort of solvency
position since world war ii the fed
doesn't really have a choice so it's not
really what should they do it's just
what are they going to do basically uh
so i if i were the fed i would uh quit
posturing about trying to valkyrie which
is just literally not possible
and um i would opt for yield curve
control right now which we have to take
our medicine basically um it's like
nobody ever wants to deleverage nobody
wants to declare bankruptcy and no one
wants to pay down their debt but you
have to yep right so that's what we are
going to have to do run inflation hot 20
30 percent for a few years get to debt
to gdp down to you know 60 70 back to a
normal historical level
but the consequence of all that is
inflation's going to be just
catastrophic like you think it's bad
today yeah catastrophic
when you think about that environment um
we've seen many people uh with access to
data sets that the government may or may
not have access to you know take jack
dorsey's probably the most well-known
one saying hey hyperinflation you know
essentially is happening uh the
situation you just described is um
to essentially cap their ability or kind
of handicap their ability to use certain
tools that central make has available to
them and really just let inflation run
wild and in that environment if the
official numbers show 20
right which sounds crazy until you're
like well it's only two and a half times
from where we are right now uh
unofficial inflation and certain people
in the economy may be experiencing 50
inflation at that point uh that's
argentina right i mean like like this is
a very serious situation is that
like your base case at this point or is
that still something that's an outlier
and you think that there's kind of this
like soft landing that they keep
pointing to no no no soft landing is
completely impossible there's no
precedent for hiking into a recession uh
successfully right and it doesn't happen
normally that's where we're going we're
hiking into recession you're making
financial conditions extra tight
um as the economy is slowing down it's
it's like ludicrous why doesn't the
mainstream media or like the legacy
finance world why don't they on see this
understand it like is it just like
they're just rep they're repeating the
talking points of the fed or is there
some divergence of like understanding of
the financial system from like i'll call
it the bitcoin community and the
non-bitcoin community because it feels
like bitcoin is all like yeah this is
like so obvious but i don't hear that
from the other uh kind of communities i
would say the press for the most part
the corporate press they're just
stenographers of power so they're just
repeating uh effectively what um
you know the press secretary and the
government tells them to right that's
their job uh is just to communicate
washington's dictates uh there i'm
seeing defections in some corners of the
msm like the new york times wrote an
interesting article recently saying hey
actually inflation is probably
undercounted and i said here's why and
i'm like oh my god they admitted it yes
we were right and we have been and
continue to be right inflation is under
counted they changed the methodology for
inflation uh to include owner's
equivalent rent and instead of looking
at actual house prices if you do
incorporate that inflation is double
digits right now so you're seeing
defections
actually in the most sort of like regime
proximate uh news sources which is
really interesting so they're kind of
breaking ranks i i have a theory as to
why uh we're going to start seeing more
of this and we have started to see a
couple is uh
one of the groups of people who actually
are not allowed to have investments are
journalists right and so if you are
essentially given artificial capital
controls by your employer that says you
have to stay in cash or cash equivalent
type assets uh
you get screwed the worst and so there's
almost this uh sensitivity like how much
pain will you take before you quote lash
out and lashing out is writing an
article that says hey everyone wake up
right this isn't real this isn't the
accurate number and so i was surprised
when i saw it but in hindsight like
that's actually a group of people that
are going to get hurt the most here and
so i wouldn't be surprised if we see
more and more people kind of defecting
from the the mainstream talking points
yeah show me the incentive and i'll show
you the outcome right and the arthur
this particular piece in the new york
times when it was notable is jenna
smielek i think she's the chief fed
writer at the new york times so if even
the top economics correspondents of the
times are saying hey guys so yeah
actually you know what uh cpi does under
count inflation uh we admit it uh that's
a sign that something's deeply wrong i
think people are seeing now um you know
the fed has not acknowledged they made
mistakes they were wrong you can't deny
that right these people look like you
know this like um inviolate uh priest
class where they're just handing down
knowledge from the heavens right
their um inadequacies have been exposed
right they have been wrong there's no
denying that they've been wrong and i
think you have to admit at this point i
think that's part of the problem is they
don't have credibility when you see that
the fed is in this position um you can
go look and there was articles that said
inflation is good because wages will go
up i think emphatically you can look at
the data real estate just went down
inflation adjusted average hourly wages
in america have been down for 14 months
right um
how bad is it for like the average
person right now official inflation's
8.6
average you know hourly wages are down
like just what is the pain how do you
think about that so
i think people uh fixate on like um you
know measures of inflation like cpi like
this and they forget what we're really
talking about which is like how much can
our fiat currency buy us in terms of
real world resources right and so the
fed's theory is basically we can induce
demand destruction we can lower asset
prices and um we can get inflation under
control by uh literally destroying our
ability to spend uh they think a lot of
it has to do with asset prices which why
they want stocks and and crypto to go
down actually uh because then you're
gonna spend less if you feel poorer
right um that's like someone compared it
to giving yourself a root canal with a
shotgun basically
decreasing everyone's aggregate wealth
in order to reduce inflation and the
thing is that might work in the short
term but the problem is in the long term
the reason we have inflation is
we have a real world resources
commodities crisis we have
deglobalization we have a shrinking
workforce
and um
we have an energy crisis
if you can't cheaply extract you know
natural gas out of the ground
that's going to be inflationary the
2010s were disinflationary because we
had this shale boom there was tons of
abundant energy that's over that time is
over it's politically difficult to
extract oil and gas from the ground so
you know the world is kind of a war the
world is fragmenting deglobalization is
occurring these are secular long-term
trends they're not going to change
so even if you do have lots of demand
destruction and you sort of temporarily
get inflation under control
the core underlying trends are not
changing
that means we're in for inflation for
the foreseeable it won't change
there's a lot of folks in the bitcoin
community who said bitcoin was an
inflation hedge uh it was at 69 000 it's
at 20 000 inflation's at 8.6
is bitcoin an inflation hedge
it's definitionally not a hedge i guess
at this point i'll look i'll admit it
okay um however has anything about
bitcoin changed no has the monetary
policy changed no is it unsound in any
way has any feature of the bitcoin
system changed no
is are the fiats of the world debauching
themselves yes unquestionably yes will
they continue to debauch themselves yes
and these are the most credible fiat
currencies in the world and it's just
total total chaos out there so
um yes has liquidity and financial
conditions affected the price of bitcoin
and all the cryptocurrencies absolutely
um does our monetary system which uh you
know the bitcoin monetary system does it
look more or less credible relative to
the outside more credible relatively
speaking because everything out there
we're looking to wave sovereign defaults
we're looking at massive devaluations
probably a lot of these weaker emerging
market currencies when the dollar
rallies merging market currencies die a
lot of these currencies are going to
fail they will cease to exist the dollar
is at generational high level of
inflation will go higher uh the yen is
you know experiencing collapse basically
so from my perspective and i know this
sounds like i'm denying reality or
something our system continues to be
sound and work perfectly
and i think it looks better relatively
speaking i obviously agree uh one of the
things uh that i think about that i
don't hear a lot of people talking about
is that if you go back to march of 2020
uh there's a liquidity crisis it was a
very sharp uh liquidity crisis and kind
of very severe uh in the sense that they
ordered everyone to go home you had got
the velocity of money to slow down
people panic there was uncertainty
public health all these things
and so correlations of all assets trend
towards one in those moments
this is also a liquidity crisis it just
is drawn out over eight months now and i
wonder how much of bitcoin's price and
kind of the divergence from the value we
see hash rate at all-time highs we see
you know lightning network capacity
growing adoption all these underlying
fundamentals and metrics
how much of price right now is just
simply correlations going towards one in
a liquidity crisis and we should expect
a decoupling of bitcoin to other assets
you know as we come out of this yeah i
think it will happen and conventional
wisdom is that um
you know the bitcoin risk asset
correlation is going to stay high
forever that's crazy
that i remember when the bitcoin risk
asset correlation was zero
and i also thought it was crazy i'm like
no it's probably going to increase
because we're having a more
institutional holder base and things
like that um if you now believe that
bitcoin is going to stay correlated with
stocks forever you're also bound to be
wrong um
the i think the analogy with 2020 is
very apt you know we rocket it off the
bottom bitcoin moves first financial
assets follow the lead because bitcoin
is basically the most liquid market
informationally efficient in the world
in my opinion
um
what also happened in march 2020 bonds
treasuries sold off alongside stocks
that's not meant to happen right they're
meant to be inversely correlated so it's
not just us that are dealing with
correlation issue it's the 60 40
portfolio where you have your stocks and
you have your bonds and in theory the
bonds rally when the stocks sell off and
vice versa
that didn't happen because now the world
is reconsidering
the prospect of the us government
defaulting we're in for an advanced
inflationary period so bonds people are
now worried about them they're selling
off at the same time so it's all asset
classes that are having this correlation
issue in the last few months there's no
safe haven it's not gold it's not stocks
it's not value it's not growth it's not
emerging markets and it's not u.s
treasuries and it's not cash either so
there's no safe haven
now um are we particularly correlated to
risk assets yes correlations are at an
all-time high
but
uh also no one else has anywhere else to
hide i think people are forgetting that
in particular treasury selling off
alongside stocks
uh that is something to be very very
nervous about
when
i asked the question about inflation
hedge uh obviously the critic will point
to well it's at 69 000
inflation is now at 8.6 percent is down
at twenty thousand it's not a hedge um
but i think that the time frame that you
analyze this is pretty important and one
of the things that seems to be
completely forgotten is you if you were
to go back to january 1st 2020 so kind
of right before the pandemic really came
to the united states uh bitcoin is up
like 300 percent it's drastically
outperformed stocks bonds other
currencies commodities real estate just
everything
how do you think about measuring whether
something has served as a good inflation
hedge or a good safe haven and are there
certain time frames that you tend to
kind of evaluate these assets on yeah i
mean like i think if you want to
understand the nature of the asset
looking at short-term
uh looking at returns looking at sharp
ratios
uh looking at volatility those are the
wrong ways to determine what the thing
is you know to understand what bitcoin
is you have to really think about it
deeply and see that it's basically a
synthetic kind of commodity
and you shouldn't make a determination
to what kind of an asset it is
based on you know three months of price
performance or two years you could do
the same with gold you know gold is
selling off right now does that mean
gold is not a good thing to hold does
that mean it's not a good savings device
no it's a good savings device you know
over long-term trends so bitcoin is so
new so everybody's trying to look at
price charts and it's return profile and
there's like these like financial
abstractions that you know they don't
actually speak to the core of what it is
and what it is is a system where you can
hold your wealth um you know personally
secretly
confidentially
and uh you know nobody can interfere
with it that's what it really is
you know and so of course like yeah
there's like volatility here and there
and that hurts right but that doesn't
speak to the true nature of the asset
and i think people miss that yeah when
you think about bitcoin moving forward
in this environment where you describe
kind of yield cult controls um high
inflation do you expect bitcoin to go
down further do you expect it kind of
just to go sideways for a while what's
your expectation for the actual price of
bitcoin we could continue puking here if
there's further cascading liquidations
um in particular the daisy chain of risk
that we're seeing from uh some of these
blow-ups that's possible i'm not ruling
it out
um if tether fails we could see another
downwards like i know there's a lot of
fear out there uh in the markets about
tether i personally don't subscribe to
those bearish views
um
all that said if there's a massive
inflationary pivot by the fight i think
the bitcoin will do well
um
if there are massive sovereign defaults
and the major fiat currencies start to
die off which basically i expect to
happen i think bitcoin will do great
um and you know frankly as inflation
picks up um that will also uh help um so
you know i can't say it's a hedge and i
can't tell you the time frame
specifically but basically the thing i
think about is for the next 10 years of
my life what would i rather own like
dollar denominated assets stocks where
the you know price earnings ratios are
still in the 30s do i want to own
government debt which is negatively
yielding uh you know in real terms right
or do i want to own this asset which is
a synthetic commodity which is finite
which i understand very well which is
held by hundreds of millions of people
worldwide to me i want to hold the
bitcoin and uh yeah like my portfolio is
going to look crazy it's going to be all
over the place
like it is this week uh but you know
ultimately to me what it really matters
is the true nature of the asset
and how it does alongside uh rapidly
depreciating fiat you talked about
liquidations and some of this cascading
risk um
explain what your thoughts are around
celsius and some of this uh kind of
staked each those seem to be the two uh
most urgent you know kind of uh current
events that people are paying attention
to how do you view those two events uh
you know given the price movements yeah
and i want to give credit to a few
people that are really loud about um
celsius and the risks there uh cory
clemenstein in particular mike alfred i
think they were they were correct and
they did warn people and i think they
probably save people money and i was
actually looking at my dms today there
are a few people dming me
they stuff like wow you saved my ass
dude and it's i look back at the chat
it's because they asked me about celsius
and i said it's probably not sound and
i'm not here to trash anyone's startup
or any protocol on crypto but it was
known that celsius was putting client
funds in d5
and they could we knew that because they
kept losing money in d5 hacks so that
was fully known and so they were
pursuing the risky strategies possible
including putting funds in anchor which
was sort of not a sustainable thing and
so based on that we kind of knew that
something all was not well
so it was kind of foreseeable
what i expect to happen with celsius is
some kind of
administration receivership uh some sort
of orderly uh bankruptcy proceeding
where we're going to find out who who's
a secured creditor and who's an
unsecured creditor unfortunately the
retail depositors celsius are unsecured
creditors and they're not going to get
100 of their stake back if i had to
guess that's going to take a while
that's going to be like the gox
proceeding the quadriga the cryptopia
those would be your templates to
understand how long is it going to take
ironically you know that means it's
going to lock up a lot of coin for a
while so that might be sort of like
conditionally positive the problem is is
that
uh these lenders are all interlinked
they all have relationships with each
other um
it's not clear what the causality is
between you know like a celsius eterra
we know that obviously celsius had funds
in terror they were able to withdraw
them uh but you know that probably also
sparked a bit of run on the bank because
people like holy crap these were putting
they were putting client funds in tara
like what else are they doing so we know
there's sort of a relationship there we
don't necessarily know the causality of
like one cause the other celsius might
have actually caused the collapse of
tether right so it could go both ways
but yeah all these um you know like big
intermediaries uh they have
relationships with each other and so
one of them failing uh kind of causes
defaults with another one and i think
that's actually what we're seeing with
the price action today you're seeing
like you know people are chasing the
stops they're trying to induce
liquidations uh trying to make these
people become for sellers you know
that's all uh that's all happening right
now uh that look that leverage is
flushing out of the system
um but yeah i think we we also probably
have some ways to go there how do you uh
respond when i see people talking online
about almost like this like gamesmanship
or this like i think i saw someone
describe it as like pvp between a lot of
these traders and trying to figure out
where the liquidation points are do you
feel like uh that's definitely happening
kind of behind the scenes that there are
uh almost these sharks or predators in
the market looking at the order books
trying to figure out where the
liquidation points are yeah completely
and that's the funny thing about d5 is
uh it's basically all public and that's
sort of not something you want i mean i
like the transparency of defy you know
it's all on the blockchain it's great
obviously i found a blockchain analytics
company so i sort of enjoy that uh for
from an analytical perspective but from
a trading perspective the thing you
never want to do is to tell the person
trading against you where you're going
to be liquidated
that's the worst thing because they're
going to make you a force seller at that
point because they know exactly what the
threshold they have to hit to screw you
over
and so
that's i think that's actually a big
part of the problem here is that celsius
had so many positions in d5 they're
basically one of the largest
entities providing liquidity to d5 and
they're levered you know they have
leverage they've got these big maker
vaults and things like that so right now
the dynamic issue of funds chasing
their stops
and it's all known and including some of
these other funds that are experiencing
distress it's the same thing there's
lots of great analytics
services out there that can use to
determine where these funds become for
sellers so that creates this crazy
dynamic and that really adds the
volatility what about staked eth or s t
eth as many people see it online yeah i
think it's trading at what 94 95 cents
on the dollar now um so the problem is
when you have these instruments that
people think are pegged to something or
are fixed in price that aren't and that
was the problem with money market mutual
funds in 2008 that was the real problems
because everybody behaved like they were
you know meant to trade at a dollar or
whatever that was the problem with ust
because people thought that it was
secure and so they sort of built
financial products on top of it and
that's also the problem with staked is
because people thought it was always
going to be worth one eath
and they built that assumption into all
these other systems
that was the problem and um steak teeth
if you understand like the nature of a
closed end trust for instance like a
grayscale gbdc you would know that it
shouldn't be trading at par
there's one
law there's one axiom in finance which
is axiomatic and true which is no
convertibility no parity
state teeth is not convertible for eath
right it's only east that's convertible
for to steak teeth it's a one-way peg
in some unknown amount of time it could
be 12 months could be 18 months uh that
steak diet will be redeemable for eth
after certain uh you know key sort of
events happen
but that's it's not convertible today so
of course it should be trading at a
discount it's a closed untrust that
always happens that's the same with uh
with gbdc basically
and the also there's a lot of
uncertainty as to when the merges can
occur and the schedule of unlocks for
the stake death so naturally it's
trading at discount it's just that
people don't have an appreciation for
these concepts they think everything is
brand new in crypto and uh there's
nothing to learn from traditional
finance right and so that's the problem
and now
it's another thing where the liquidation
thresholds are known so there's also an
incentive to attack it and there's all
these entities that have staked
that treat it as uh equivalent to eth
and they now have to get out of the
position and the problem is they don't
want to take a haircut to do that but
they have to so you talked about the
transparency of defy uh there's some
downsides to it in terms of the
transparency as well but um there's a
whole group of people in the bitcoin
community that thinks uh we're gonna
take all the d5 ideas it's kind of r d
on these other chains and eventually
build it on top of bitcoin whether
that's on top of lightning or in some
other capacity
do you think that that's a realistic uh
kind of path or outcome uh over the long
run for these d5 type applications or do
you think that actually we'll get kind
of both right because i think the
bitcoin price still keep doing uh this
work but do you think the other stuff
kind of survives if you will yeah it's
funny because i uh was a co-author on a
paper that argued this recently um with
ross stevens and allen farrington uh
knight egg published it i recommended
you read it and the the idea there was
like yeah d5 is like deeply flawed and
uh lightning or bitcoin is a stable
foundation and you know i do believe
that bitcoin is the most stable
foundation we're seeing what happens
when you build on an unstable foundation
like a solana for instance you know
people get really skittish about putting
liquidity on there uh if the blockchain
can go down kind of the same thing with
ethereum like there's a lot of questions
about the merge and what it's going to
look like when's that you know going to
happen
um and and you know financial products
they need to be like ironclad you know
they need to really work and be
predictable
um all that said
i don't think you can deny that there's
a huge amount of momentum built to up in
uh kind of defy on smart contract
platforms like i don't know how much tvl
there is
on ethereum based d5 but i believe it's
in the hundreds of billions it's a lot
maybe it's less today actually um
that's not that doesn't mean that
there's like value there necessarily
like tara had tvl in the
tens of billions and that if you were
valuing tara on the basis of that tbl
that was illusory but um i also don't
think you can deny that there's this
infrastructure that works and that you
know east d5 is a big head start and
also the culture is different right like
bitcoiners are generally not willing to
do token-based issuance to subsidize
liquidity in defy which puts rocket fuel
under your protocol whether it's prudent
or not whereas you do see that in sort
of ethereum land or the other smart
contract chain so um i think bitcoin
itself
optimizes uh for one thing which is
really
cultivating the bitcoin utxo set and
there's actually a bunch of decisions in
the history of bitcoin where you look
back they actually didn't want foreign
assets to be circulating on bitcoin uh
i think lightning is an excellent
substrate for
uh stablecoin transactions so i'm
keeping an eye on the tarot system and
the potential insertion of stable coins
back into lightning because that's a
very lightweight and data efficient way
to transact and that's what stablecoin
users want is
low fees and that's why we see a lot of
stablecoins on tron
all that said the sort of natively
composable infrastructure that we see
in in established d5
um i probably have a hard time seeing
that built on bitcoin and it's sort of
okay you know you can have bitcoin
denominated d5 occurring
on ethereum via a virus rap bitcoin
product so i actually think that's sort
of the more likely outcome
is that um you know bitcoin ends up
being bridged to all these other
blockchains and they become a
transactional venue for units of bitcoin
now a lot of purists don't like that
they're gonna say it's not real bitcoin
but uh just realistically speaking i
think that's sort of gonna be the
outcome here we've seen a bunch of uh
conversation publicly uh from regulators
policymakers uh luna terror situation uh
obviously blows up people start saying
hey there needs to be more regulation uh
we've seen uh senator lummus and senator
gildebrand put forward some legislation
around uh how we should regulate various
assets what's security what's not a
security
what do you kind of evaluate the current
regulatory environment and do you think
that we're headed towards significantly
more regulation in the coming months and
years absolutely uh it's going to depend
what happens in congress i think even a
fully
republican
congress let's say they win both houses
in november is still interested in
crypto regulation because
you get regulatory advances when people
lose money
you look at uh the financial crisis of
1929 we got the sec in 1934.
you look at
the dot-com bubble
uh and that financial crisis we got
glass-steagall after that
you look at 2009
2008
you got um well dodd-frank
so
you always get significant regulatory
developments after a crisis because
there's political
um will to do that a lot of people lost
money in celsius a lot of people are
gonna lose money lost money and just
like crypto generally um there will be
appetite for that and you'll actually
see the opinions of uh crypto market
participants reflect this people are
evolving their views like huh maybe
actually there should be some safeguards
and maybe uh you know there should be
some disclosure standards here like
maybe the fully anarchic world is not
the one we want
how much of that is um
if you look at bitcoin as an example
i've seen multiple studies it used to be
100 of people who in bitcoin only owned
bitcoin right now was because bitcoin
was the only kind of game in town now
one of the latest studies i've seen
shows 87 percent of people who hold
bitcoin hold at least one other token
and that could be a stable coin or that
could be something you know super risky
and d fire whatever um
how much of like the change in
regulatory perspective of the industry
is just like new people coming in who
maybe didn't subscribe to the old
viewpoint versus it's actually a
transition people who used to think hey
no regulation or whatever they're
actually changing their mind and that's
affecting kind of the overall industry
perspective yeah that's a great point i
mean how many people worldwide would you
say have exposure to crypto assets
generally like 2 300 million i think
there's a world bank study
a lot of those came in the last couple
years and for a lot of them their first
brush with crypto was actually nfts
or it was
something the binance smart chain or
solana ecosystem or as a d5 protocol
those people i think will they're
they're not necessarily the earliest
adopters so they maybe didn't learn that
much about key management uh they didn't
learn the sort of uh cypherpunk ideology
or anything like that right we can't
expect them to and they'll probably be
much more open to um the establishment
of regulatory confines now that's not to
say there's no regulation in the crypto
industry uh but yeah i do think that the
holder base as this is today
is actually probably more open to some
sort of regulatory imposition
now i hope that it sort of looks like
the llamas gillibrand bill as opposed to
like the stable act or something or uh
you know the token taxonomy act
so i hope that we get it right and i
think we do have
some of the right parties in congress to
get it right and they're getting the
right advice
but yeah i think it's inevitable at this
point i think it'll concern stable coins
it'll concern crypto exchanges i think
the listing standards of crypto
exchanges will change they will have to
change it'll concern d5 protocols with
um
right now it's just gray market
liquidity nobody knows who's trading
with whom that's probably going to
change frankly you're going to see more
permission liquidity um and you know
it'll concern uh token issuance right of
course
um so yeah i think it'll be really
really material
and uh you'll see certain countries clam
up completely and basically trying to
outlaw crypto yeah talk about miners
obviously uh if we go back to kind of q1
of 2021 uh mining was 65 in china and
spread out the rest uh throughout the
world uh china banned it we had a
migration to the united states i think
the u.s now is over 30 percent of all uh
hash rate globally texas has like 10
or something like that um
what are the ramifications of price
going down for the miners and should we
expect any kind of uh pressure from them
or does this actually benefit them so
this is another shoe to drop i hate to
tell you all but um miners have like
public miners if you add it up they've
got go to like bitcointreasures.com
they've got like 40 50 000 bitcoin
sitting there
so they've got almost one
tara's worth of bitcoin you know there's
a lot of bitcoin they have because the
public market's rewarded the miners that
accumulate a lot of bitcoin didn't sell
it that was sort of the metagame get as
much bitcoin as possible don't sell it
so it's a pro cyclical
phenomenon it means that they make the
bull markets steeper and the bear
markets worse the same thing happened in
2018. miners
i think the last leg down
in 2018 or 2019 to 3 000 i think that
actually was minor selling driven
um if you sort of like do the uh the
ancient archaeology now if you look
on chain i know people say like on chain
has no alpha or whatever just look at it
guys there's some interesting stuff
there
um
miners are
selling
well you don't have to look on chain you
could look at the balance sheets you
look at the sec blockchain or like look
at the sec filings right the sec
yeah yeah it's on it's all it's all on a
ledger somewhere yeah so miners are
selling their bitcoin they have a lot
more bitcoin to sell and they're going
to sell it for a number of reasons a lot
of them are out of business they can't
afford their next payment um
they're just not going to exist in a
year's time so there can be insolvencies
there a lot of them are too highly
levered and they're not going to be able
to pay their uh pay their bills
whether it's power or they're not going
to be able to make interest payments um
and they'll be out of business
a lot of miners will buy the now
bankrupt competitor miners
they're going to buy with bitcoin on
their balance sheet right
or cash but you know bitcoin is a liquid
asset that they've ready to go so
there'll be a wave of consolidation all
that means is that a lot of the bitcoin
that the miners accumulated will be
liquidated and this has kind of been my
view since we saw the liquidations in
2018 as miners are this pro cyclical
force
which i think is a very different view
from like the stock to flow narrative
where you know
the stock to flow narrative it doesn't
uh incorporate what minor behavior it
really is and their actual behavior is
during the you know bull phases they
want to hold the bitcoin and then during
market downturns they're forced to sell
the bitcoin
and uh we haven't seen that completed
yet but i think we will
and so for me that would be actually
bottom signal once they're done
liquidating all their bitcoins how would
you know that they're done
you could look on chain you can look um
at a lot of them are publicly traded so
you can see
they'll have to announce it yeah and
when you think about those miners uh do
you expect hash rate to come down as
they're doing some of this some of them
go out of business or should we expect
hash rate to continue to hit all-time
highs and grow like what's your
expectations there double whammy
hashtable can keep growing so if as a
minor the worst possible thing to happen
is the price of bitcoin to fall and hash
rate to grow right because that means
hash rate grows that means that your
constant hash rate you're sure if the
pie is shrinking your amount of bitcoin
mine is less
um that's happening continue to happen
and that's going to make it very very
challenging to be a minor if you're not
the most efficient
and so there'll be a big push towards
efficiency towards cheap power
acquisition
towards long-term ppas towards being
vertically integrated so maybe you own
the underlying power asset so i think
it's healthy overall it forces miners to
find uh the cheapest power possible the
most uh oftentimes most sustainable
because uh solar and wind have no um
you don't have to like use fuel to
generate those power sources they have
no real um
uh
sort of like
ongoing costs once they're put in the
ground um so i think it'll actually be a
drive towards you know creativity among
minors
um but yeah
i think it's gonna be a really really
challenging time in the public minor
space and i think we'll see a lot of
consolidation my last question is around
geopolitics uh we've obviously seen the
russia ukraine situation there was a ton
of crypto not just bitcoin but all kinds
of assets that were donated there i
think that was a positive story uh
inside of the bitcoin community the el
salvador story i think it's been a very
positive kind of oh look what is
possible uh the central africa republic
i think is the name of the organization
right uh um has
become very
bitcoin friendly maybe
say i don't know exactly what they've
done or haven't done but but they seem
to be very uh interested how do you
think about nation states and bitcoin
when the price is at 69 000 it sounds a
lot better than when it's at 20 000. but
we also have boot kelly you know
tweeting saying maybe i should buy more
like how do you think about this yeah i
mean
basically i think the
you know the russia conflict that
provoked the us sanctions and uh
completely unprecedented kind of thing
russia's 11th largest economy in the
world and uh we froze their
their central bank assets which is the
accumulated surplus of an entire nation
so basically an act of theft in my
opinion uh those sanctions uh are
failing they're not working right and so
the moral justification for them is
really it looks weak now um it's funny i
think the last time i was on your show
was the day before the russia invasion
i believe you were um and uh you know
for i i'll fess up i think i said russia
is not going to invade ukraine so i got
that one wrong
um a lot of us were wrong but the
sanctions to me was incredibly dramatic
and it meant that people are no longer
trusting us treasuries because if the us
is willing to do that to russia they'll
do it to anyone i'm a huge nation huge
enemy everyone's dependent on russian
energy
uh at the end of the day uh so i think
that's sort of the key geopolitical
story is i think you will see that
nation states defecting from the u.s led
order that to me is the big story of the
decade here el salvador is doing that
now did they do it at the right entry
prices maybe not you know central
african republic look at their discourse
it's the same thing it's all about a
neutral monetary asset read the
president's tweets he's on twitter they
haven't verified him president of
central african republic
um he's a mathematician he's two phds
yeah he's not an idiot no he's an
incredibly smart guy two phds yeah how
many heads of state have two phds in
math yeah so he understands that if you
look at what him and buchelli say uh and
actually look at what uh russia has to
say about bitcoin or ukraine even it's
all about a neutral asset they can't be
interfered with everybody benefits from
that
you know including like two belligerents
on the opposite side of a war talk about
money for enemies right they're both
saying pro bitcoin stuff now
uh so you know generally speaking as the
world's global reserve currency becomes
highly highly politicized and it becomes
our tool for strategic um uh you know
power projection right which is the way
the us uses the dollar people looking
for alternatives so i do think this is
the decade of sovereign adoption
the first few countries that you know
cross the threshold they probably took a
bit of a loss on the price of bitcoin
but long term if they hold the line they
treat it like long-term holding i think
they're going to be just fine and i
think the earliest adopters are still
going to do great
i uh i tend to agree completely that
the neutrality
seems weird because we've never seen
that before we're not used to it
but at the end of the day if you were to
redesign a system neutrality would be at
the heart of it yeah i mean if it's a
monetary network you want a network
where there's no political
um
barriers to being a node on that network
right the the u.s dollar network is
highly pitilitized in so many different
ways so the sovereign level all the way
down to the individual level the bitcoin
network doesn't care and that's why it's
a fundamentally better system that's why
it's going to win yeah i could literally
talk to you for like 20 hours uh where
can we send people to find you on the
internet um twitter nick underscore
underscore carter that's two underscores
don't get that wrong
there is another one underscore nick
carter out there poor guy probably gets
mentioned a lot i don't know what's
going on with him probably gets a lot of
followers people looking for you and get
confused and i will say um i'm 50 of the
way to the nick carter flipping
against the backstreet boy nick carter
so um you know please help me out i want
to become the number one nick carter in
the world
uh he also likes cordano
so that's another reason that you should
follow me and not him should we should
we have you both come on the show and do
like a nick nick carter yeah i want to
debate him yeah i want to debate him how
long do you think he would last in a
debate with you you know i think he's a
pretty sharp guy he's he's a better
singer than me
probably better looking you talk he
sings and we'll see what happens um yeah
so i want to face him down nick carter
uh let's let's debate
all right well thank you for coming in i
think people learned a a ton uh there
was people in the beginning here like
who is this guy he's got great content
so i think you're uh you're doing
something right um and uh
we will definitely have you come back
again uh and know backstreet is not back
ladies and gentlemen so thanks so much
take care talk soon